we're going to begin with the ongoing
threat to the state of texas with
tropical storm nicholas which slammed
into the state overnight as a hurricane
new video shows the system pounding the
coast it blasted ashore with winds of
more than 75 miles an hour more than
seven inches of rain have already fallen
in the houston area flooding roads and
downing trees and power is out for more
than 300 thousand customers janet
chamblion is in kemah that is near
houston janet good morning
tony good morning to you why you are
along galveston bay in the community of
kemah a coastal community where you can
see what hours of rain has done to the
roads here but it is not just the rain
that wind has plunged communities into
darkness and the number of customers
without power is growing every few
minutes this is the same area that was
slammed by hurricane harvey in 2017 with
a record 60 inches of rain nicholas is
not that storm but already the governors
of texas and louisiana have asked for
federal aid and this is coming just two
weeks after hurricane ida slammed
louisiana take a look at what's
happening in this region in the
community of freeport where roads are
covered with water and visibility is
almost zero in some areas this is
definitely a big rainmaker besides the
power outages wind gusts have been
bringing down trees this one slamming
into a recreational vehicle no one was
hurt there now even before landfall
nicholas pelted the coast with more than
70 mile an hour wind gusts damaging this
gas station and this is early we're
going to get a better look at damage in
the next couple of hours
back here in kemah and throughout
southeast texas officials are asking
people just to stay put right now to
buckle down do not go outside there are
traffic lights out all over the region
and a lot of the roads look like this
it's going to be like this throughout
the day gail
all right that does not look like a good
day there thank you janet